madame monsieur bonjour messe de
funéraille de la baie pierre ce matin la
cathédrale Notre-Dame de Paris son
cercueil porté par des compagnons
desmaus a été béni par Monseigneur André
23 archevêc de Paris qui a célébré la
messe en présence du président de la
République Jacques Chirac et des
représentant des Maus du monde entier
une cérémonie extrêmement émouvante
Claude
sampère l'hommage de toute une nation
pour son Abé plusieurs milliers de
personnes rassemblai ce matin devant la
cathédr
NotreDame dès l'arrivée du cercueil des
applaudissement pour saluer laabé pierre
un geste rare en France l'UR d'obsè un
geste à l'image du
personnage à l'intérieur de nouveau
quelques applaudissements certains
touchent le cercueil lors de son
[Applaudissements]
passage
au premier rang le président de la
République dans la foule les compagnons
desmaus l'ABB les voula présent et n'
pas relégué au dernier rang ils sont là
à ses
côtés l'abbé voulait une cérémonie
simple le cercueil est posé à même le
sol quelques instants plus tard on
dépose dessus la célèbre de l'abé pierre
et sonne grand cro de la Légion
[Musique]
d'honneur minutes plus tard l'évêque de
Grenoble dépose l'aube et les toes
violettes rappelant que l'abé pierre
était
prêtre dès le début de la cérémonie le
président des Maus France prononce
quelques mot célébrer une cérémonie à la
cathédrale Notre-Dame de Paris merci
d'être
ici merci
d'agir d'agir pour tous ceux qui
comptaient sur la baie pierre pour
reconquérir leur
dignité qui comptait sur sa manière
incomparable
de
déranger de
bousculer les conventions les usages les
puissants pour la juste cause le
véritable
hommage sera de Contin continuer son
combat à l'intérieur de la cathédrale
des personnalité Politi de prier
rang
[Musique]
à chaque étape de la cérémonie très
digne on sent transparaître la
personnalité de l'abbé
Pierre sa vie c'est
combat le cardinal Barbarin archevêque
de Lyon am de la BA pierre
prononce droit à un logement décent où
il puisse vivre avec les siens
50 ans plus tard l'aventure continue et
le combat est loin d'être gagné l'abbé
Pierre ne l'abandonnera jamais il a
communiqué son élan à beaucoup d'autres
l'an dernier encore au mépris de ses 93
ans il a repris son bâton de pèlerin
pour aller à l'Assemblée nationale
supplier les députés d'agir en faveur
des mal
logés non seulement il a toujours
défendu les pauvres mais il a vécu
lui-même comme un
pauvre pour célébrer la messe
Monseigneur André archevê de Paris
monseigur rard archev de Bordeaux ainsi
que Monseigneur lu le cardinal
Barbarin de ton serviteur Henri l'AB
pierre une cérémonie de près de 2 he
très simple et très
belle la messe achevée il y a quelques
minutes par un message d'hommage du
Saint-Père l'abé pierre parlait de la
mort comme une rencontre avec un
ami tous les gens qui étai présents ce
matin lui souhaitent maintenant une très
belle
[Musique]
rencontre